how's it going everybody it's Warren and
with Avengers in game being in theaters
for a little over three weeks we finally
got to see that one scenario out of the
14 million 605 that Doctor Strange saw
now sadly that one scenario in which the
Avengers won and defeated Thanos both of
the present and of the past involved our
beloved Black Widow and Tony Stark dying
it was of course heartbreaking but
according to what Doctor Strange and
Avengers infinity war there was no other
way and of course an Avengers in Game
Doctor Strange did confirm that it was
in fact that one scenario but it had to
involve Ironman dying in Avengers
infinity war he told Tony Stark that
there was only one scenario in which
they won and then when he returned in
Avengers in game Tony Stark asked if
they were currently in that one scenario
and Doctor Strange told him that he
couldn't tell him and the writers for
Avengers infinity war and Avengers in
game have recently opened up about these
two scenes about what Doctor Strange
really meant when he told Tony those two
things screenwriters Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely said in a recent
interview the only way this works is if
Tony dies if you go back and watch
infinity war when Doctor Strange says 1
Benedict is just choked on emotion now
that you know the end go back and watch
that moment he means you're going to
have to die Tony how many ruin the plan
always involved Tony dying a lot of
people ask why did Tony have to snap
maybe he could have just used some of
the Infinity stones against Stannis or
maybe he could have given the gauntlet
to Captain Marvel but according to the
writers and Doctor Strange there was no
other way this had to happen Christopher
Markus said we had the opportunity to
give him the perfect retirement life
within the movie then stephen mcfeely
added he got that already then
Christopher Markus said that's the life
he's been striving for are he and pepper
going to get together
yes they got married they had a kid it
was great it's a good death it doesn't
feel like a tragedy it feels like a
heroic a finished life so again I know
some people have said that there are
plot holes because Tony Stark it didn't
actually have to snap but he did the
truth of the matter is Doctor Strange
saw 14 million six hundred and five
different scenarios
The Avengers went against Thanos and the
only one won and in that one scenario
Tony Stark had to die which we saw play
out in Avengers end game and of course
Doctor Strange knew this the whole
entire time and if we go back and watch
him tell Tony one we can see him get a
little choked up because he knows that
Tony has to die so despite the fact that
we want Robert Downey jr. Tony Stark
slash Iron Man to be around forever it
had to come to an end for him but let me
know your favorite Iron Man MCU moment
in the comments down below and let me
know what you think about dr. Strange's
reaction when he has to tell Tony won
and a reminder about my giveaway at the
400,000 subscriber mark I'll be picking
three winners to each choose one item
from the Marvel Legends series
collection all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]